[MUSIC PLAYING]
ALEX DANILO: Google Maps
provides a suite of APIs
to let developers
access location data.
We'll cover some pitfalls
and best practices
for using the web service
APIs in your mobile app.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Pinging the server
regularly, like, for example,
once a minute, will
force the radio to wake
up and drain the user's
battery very quickly.
Where possible, you should
batch up requests and send them
all at once.
This means the radio only
needs to power up once
for a number of
requests, the result
being a lot less power
consumed and happier users.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Don't ping on the first
second of each minute.
Applications that
ping on the minute
are more likely to
hit usage limits.
APIs typically impose
limits on the number
of queries per second.
So for example, if your
application pulls the API
once a minute, and
you do the pulling
in the exact same second
of every minute for all
your users, you'll reach
your limit very quickly.
By randomizing the
pulling interval,
you reduce the chance
of exceeding your quota.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Now let me tell you about the
importance of using an API key.
See, if you connect to a
GOAPI service without a key,
Google will use the IP
address of the device
to count the number of requests.
Even if your app is small
and doesn't hit usage limits
on its own, not
using a key means
you share quota with all
other apps on the same device.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
When using an API key,
it's super important
to keep that key out of
your application binary,
because it's trivial
to reverse engineer
any binary to find a key.
And if that happens,
any third party
could start using
Google services
and charging the
usage to your account.
So don't do it.
Instead, you can
use a proxy server
to make the API requests
on your app's behalf.
Whoa!
That was a lot of info.
But trust me, it is worth
it, because knowing all this
makes your app that much leaner,
better, and easier to build.
So check out the
documentation on these links,
and start building
great apps using Maps.
That was a lame joke, wasn't it?
MALE SPEAKER: Mmm.
ALEX DANILO: Should
we do it again?
MALE SPEAKER: Eh.
ALEX DANILO: Nah.
[MUSIC PLAYING]